moi je serais heureux et fier lorsque
l'europe aura réussi à se mettre
d'accord
et lorsque nous serons effectivement
dans la sortie effective de ce produit
et lorsque nous aurons trouvé les moyens
d'accompagner les agriculteurs
c'est ça la question qui se pose la
question c'est la journée au seuil et de
lui reprendre son indécence la question
qui se pose c'est c'est une décision
européenne c'est une robe heureuse
aujourd'hui est-ce que si ce n'est des
fêtes pour l'europe aujourd'hui mais
c'est une défaite pour l'europe parce
que l'europe n'a pas pu trouver une
position 14 pays se sont voté pour
contrer des réalisations à 54,16 la
dernière fois nous la position du
gouvernement elle est claire c'est
trouver les conditions d'une sortie
acceptable pour les agriculteurs et
faire en sorte que nous puissions les
accompagner dans cette danse est sorti
et aujourd'hui nous sommes sur cette
ligne et moi je serais heureux lorsque
nous aurons trouvé les moyens de cette
sortie acceptable
et lorsque l'europe aura réussi à se
mettre d'accord donc il faut que l'on
continue à travailler à aller chercher
des alliés parce que notre objectif
final et je le partage avec nicolas
hulot c'est bien évidemment la sortie
des des pesticides mais aussi
l'accompagnement et tout le monde vient
là dessus les ong comme l'ensemble des
acteurs viennent sur cette position de
soutien aux dribbles nous allons partir
de cette politique est-ce que vous êtes
en train de nous dire que la france doit
transiger sur la question et accepter ce
délai de cinq ans qui est assez
communément admis et que même les
écologistes au parlement européen avait
accepté d'ailleurs avait avait avalisé
oui devait cette position de l
avortement qui pouvait mais moi j'avais
quand j'avais proposé le 21 septembre
dernier une période de cinq ans c'était
une période de cinq ans non pas pour
ensuite porter un autre renouvellement
c'était une période de cinq ans en sort
avec un phasing out une sortie et moi je
suis pour la sortie dans cinq ans
aujourd'hui quand aujourd'hui la
position du gouvernement
vous l'avez vous de l'avant ses droits
en fonction de matignon ces quatre ans
ces quatre ans la position du
gouvernement a lancé la position du
gouvernement n'a dépassé à 30,7 mais je
pense qu'on a des fantasmes agissions du
goût
le mans est sûre et sur quatre ans mon
collègue a précisé qu' il le souhaitait
que cela puisse se faire voler le la dès
3 ans oui nicolas hulot tout à fait mais
aujourd'hui elle n'avait pas d'accord ce
n'est pas une question de ne pas être
d'accord monsieur la question agace
n'est pas question aujourd'hui c'est que
la france n'est pas toute seule la
france n'agit pas seul la faire à cette
semaine c'est ça il faut faire des
premiers commence elle doit aller
chercher des alliés elle doit aller
chercher des alliés l'objectif moi ce
qui m'importe c'est que lorsque l'on
aura dessiné la temporalité le tempo de
sortie de ce produit c'est comment nous
accompagnons les les agriculteurs et
ceux qui sont les utilisateurs de ce
type de produits c'est la seule chose
qui m'intéresse c'est la seule chose qui
m'importe moi je ne fais pas de de
pseudo je dirais histoire sur un an de
plus un an de moins
ce qui m'importe c'est que demain et
c'est là qu'est ce qu'on veut 1 quelle
sera que l'on vote mais nous ne sommes
pas tout seul à voter quelle sera la
position de l'europe lors du prochain
vote